welcome to this video yum play computer
possible here on chess.com trying to
challenge this bloody machine again from
match off yeah let's say about yeah I
know a couple of games don't want to
make this like ours but yeah for a
couple of games okay Bishop f4 yeah he's
attacking the sea porn or it is
attacking the Seaport my usual problem
with playing with the comp wow long
castles hmm yeah there are ideas I just
like putting a knight on d5 that could
be very problematic and now yeah one it
can take on c5 maybe Bishop d6 coming I
take with the pawn bishop p6s downright
fatal so I probably have to take with
the Queen yeah that's not that great
idea castles bishop d6 hmm not good yeah
I can get a night to see 50 Queen a5 is
probably they are probably just taken
yeah are not a nice position night see
594 would help somehow but computer
right just go Queen to g5 or it look
like that and after that I really don't
know how to protect the pawn here ya
light c5 Queen g5 and what then Luke g8
how ugly is that but I really don't know
what to do night might come to be five
yes auto f5 hmm
night f5
yeah that's basically basically lost
yeah i really don't have a defense
against this night be 51 idea five-block
cannot cover g7 after that
chan 95 I mean or this I mean it's both
terrible even just have three wins call
that one
okay wow how bad was that I'm not really
sure what what was wrong what went wrong
there was c5 really that bad probably it
was yeah I'm the c5 move making the dark
squares probably this was really fatal
okay let's see now probably a sloth No
okay so computers playing simple simple
stuff may be here 9075 this kind of
thing okay so yeah I really didn't want
the computer to play a floor maybe I
should kick the bishop okay you form now
coming with 92 d5 I have come to play
though jump maybe maybe it's still okay
why not this fee for pushes irritating
if I go night h4 here by the way pusher
be 65 can take on d5 okay not good so
how am I going to continue here maybe
prepare for you for yeah I know I know
it plays you for itself I know my idea
was to push on the queenside now with
before try to play here on using myspace
advantage okay now i can play see 50
five looks looks quite ok and now a 3 or
yeah I guess III yeah be sick son that's
a good move 94 coming not maybe this
computer is just giving this let's check
him ok ok batik now and go night a three
so that I actually have night coming to
be five it's maybe not that bad yeah
light to be five Queen has to go to be
eight then that really has no other way
to defend the bishop ok they need to
complete or connect yeah I guess bishop
d2 or is there some way to trap this I
mean g3 you will say it would sacrifice
and I don't really want that that I mean
it's not that type of position you want
against the computer really rather want
to want to trade rooks here or something
yeah maybe rook a one to get get this
traded
Brooksie oneness now that's okay trying
to invade ultimately on c6 for example
but this Bishop to d7 I that's not
leading to much hmm how do I play that
it still this is a bit awkward for black
with this this Bishop on edge too but
how do I really benefit from that my
bishop he is not that great go into a
six maybe ought to a seven this kind of
thing hmm ok now maybe a check the h4
pawn this is somewhat somewhat loose
porn I can also try to attack the pawn
here on b6 not sure maybe this like
Bishop a6 getting this involved now
maybe try to activate if I go b5 this
trip to d6 coming
no I should go to c6 actually this this
is like okay this is almost a
self-penned now yeah I'm not sure how to
really really make progress okay g4s he
really at exit really checking here hmm
yeah maybe gphone and yeah well my my
stuffy is not exactly well placed night
b5 g4 hmm
whoo that was not good I should have
really tried to defend against us but
yeah yeah yeah it was a totally
ridiculous IDM this Bishop stuff moving
the bishop somewhere ok so like f for
now trying to prevent Knight to g5 or is
this is this not not a big deal yeah
when you probably notice I have no real
plan here that's the biggest problem I
don't really see anything great that i
can do i can just go here known bishop
g1
yeah g5g for him pretty simple but it
totally killed me yeah I have no defense
a bishop g1 and that's it yeah gathers
this was like a totally terrible game
what a plate here I mean it was
certainly okay at first but I really had
no no way to no way to make anything
happen on the queenside very bad now
let's see computer place with e3 pretty
conservative set up call the system not
bad just um slightly yeah let's say
unambitious okay maybe I can get an
isolated queen porn position which um
with the computers to play very actively
to get something going an ID 5 is a good
start of that should be five or so is
this is a threat now okay
a queen 84 may be simply I don't know
the queen that before Queen a4 of course
was what I was trying to say okay hmm
yeah I'm not well very well developed
jam and if I go Bishop e7 or something
like that there is there is Queen Queen
comin that's a terrible position against
the computer it's it's it's open totally
open and the tactics tactics of bound
yeah well I cannot give up a 60 probably
have to do that yes of course it's not
good just start a good position question
is the capture on a four on maybe I just
let them capture okay so computer does
not take material right away so I don't
know how to avoid this kind of thing and
what now can I go a five maybe trying to
secure now try to secure the porn for
the moment you should be for ya might
have knigu
hard to keep the pawn him I wonder if I
should maybe just play 97 or something
trying to trade off stuff and at the end
yeah let's do that and at the end try to
get counterplay simply against be form
with wire before against them against d
4 + b2 okay so who computer actually
allows this and now Mia no I can I can
take on e5 or i can play Knight f6 I
guess Knight f6 looks better so that I
have from 95 okay Queen blue 74 counter
play against the beeper huh so okay but
I cannot take it I see I cannot take it
because a rupee one but I can actually
play your work b8 improving this hmm
what happens cannot just take between
now why is this is impossible somehow I
don't see a tactic why it should be
impossible okay the check I see rook
could be 70 s this is this the problem
would be seven there's some tactic on
the back rank that I don't see
Queen a six Luke chicks at seven Quincy
eight made in this kind of thing hmm
look FH is so very ugly move but rugby
7s really not playable young rook piece
o Queen a six about have Quincy one
check and rook takes a seven maybe it's
playable then it always feels like
against the comp that there is something
going on I have the feeling that this is
not working yeah some crap move like
that you know harmony over yeah and this
is the killer Quincy adium you just
you'd see ya that there is a problem and
you still still don't see why it as a
problem oh man dad even that ya cannot
even even go to a crap endgame know it's
like totally lost right away and you see
I actually see that it is not working
and you still play the more I was pretty
sure that it shouldn't work but I
couldn't see how so I played it anyway
and of course I was completely fine yeah
there was nothing going on really
computer plate this really really badly
and go going into the simplified
position yeah okay come on let's get a
rematch going
let's see okay well d 4 is in general
not bad a DM maybe Knight f3 or
something okay okay I don't want the end
game but not right away rather have a
closed position where the computer is
sometimes doing doing crazy things let's
see if how it is playing so we am ok I
guess just this it's a little bit like
the classical kings in the n-word ok I'm
going to see let's see I can computers
allowing this this type of setup that
normally is quite promising from wide
what about if i push the edge pawn I
have not cancelled yet trying to
ultimately close the kingside like that
g5g for he can take or it can take but I
can play f3 + g for which would create
the ideal clamp on the key on the Kings
side ok this is actually the perfect
position against the computer b5 is not
possible
okay now and b5 is possible do I go if
why I guess I do hear the comp has no no
opportunity to play a 5 to completely
block it and here there is spawn to a
five-point a five year old computer
cannot take between that's really not
possible the queen is strapped down
after Queen d3 or something like that
okay um so I'm going to take here or not
take yer this may be really clean be
true happening I can take a sec I can't
no not not right away hmm
yeah come on let's take their and now
what now computer has the week the week
a pawn but how do I get maximum pressure
look a to probably I first yep and then
double-double against the a pawn rook a
tune and rook a one looks like a good
idea ultimately I have to play before of
course question is how to prepare it
first thing is I want to try to trade
the bishops on a four get rid of the the
light squared bishops a play Bishop a
four will it sacrifice on g4s this looks
crazy but not sure that I want to allow
that ready
huh
that's not really working probably but
it takes I have Queen Queen D one at the
end come on that's not really working
the sacrifice Bishop c4 can I believe
that okay so it wasn't it wasn't
happening so I got rid of the light
squared Bishop how do I get before and
at the end yeah i guess the knight on c3
year should be maybe reroute it and i
can also put something on a fire first
yeah night to be six of course but I go
to a three that's not a big deal and I
was thinking maybe my bishop and the
bishop can do something okay so hmm
Queen trade green trade would be nice
actually but ok I'm just going to kick
the Queen back right here so that it
come to F Canada so I can come to f5
bishops III to cover the whole thing
just for the moment yeah kind of cover
everything and now let's put put a night
on f5 let's black you defend so why now
the King over to d3 next step this is a
slow-motion chest but it is it is
improving in small steps but ultimately
improving so get get rid of one pair of
rooks
and queen a FOIA 3d Queens is basically
winning okay avoided that so we need to
trade the rest iam how do we do that
rook III rugby three he's always tied
2-2 the defense here with us against the
night on f5 yeah that's very nice let's
get all of this traded well no my king
is going to catch the a porn oh that's a
very nice game I really like that okay
let's see Bishop f5 fam to make sure
that night c7 is not happening okay here
we just trade this that's that's by far
the easiest and now the king is invading
to get the airport um the check yeah
probably the check
now can porn and Gambia's mean is quite
nice
yeah that was a very nice positional
game that you sometimes still can get
against those kind of slightly slightly
weaker computers still get some tactical
position and it will kick your butt not
okay so the only thing is not allowing
stalemate so check here king of seven
and then between g8 m8 nice yeah that's
the kind of thing you want want against
the comp everything closed yeah so you
can can dominate him nicely okay try try
again it's very difficult to keep an
even score against the machine I really
know that it's it's difficult let's see
with black it's notoriously tricky okay
hmm yeah what about the stone wall maybe
the stone wall okay so much for the
stone wall huh okay I think there is
this check and then be should be six but
now I can probably just straight yeah
why not
okay maybe just here and trade things
okay maybe just today seven I am ok
wants to attack directly in the center
yeah that's not that's not very very
nice I don't like that very much maybe
yeah okay maybe try to simplify then
Bishop g7 to c6 this kind of thing I
Bishop c4 yeah that's a good idea okay
on whatever the computer does not really
have an idea but a good maneuver or
whatever okay I'm fine now I don't need
to take right away
yeah very ugly position can I if I take
now is there how bad is that maybe I can
do that actually rook takes nights if I
a 95 a thought well not it's not like
great but maybe I still a bearable takes
c6 yeah maybe or okay I both know yeah i
was thinking maybe like be six but
that's not really really great as well
okay we'll attack here coo coo coo coo
coo create or something so this is this
rook here on the fourth-ranked is real
nuisance you can go all the way to
deform things like that and then maybe
maybe i can somehow no i cannot have
rook to e3 rook f6 still should be okay
okay i can create one pair of rooks I
cannot okay maybe here then I know then
rook GG 6 mm yeah but it's not a problem
i can take edge 5 rupees 6s on a problem
i just take h5 now or not this sir so
terrible yeah somehow I have defended
this it wasn't nice at all but ok so
keep some some material on the board
it's nothing really threatening right I
can actually expand the BGM yeah I mean
do this this starts to get pretty normal
without any any problems I mean Roxy 5g
for I can do that doubling I mean before
he's got c4 which is pro pretty much
leading to nothing maybe I can can just
attack the same
I tending to go here and now i can give
this check so that he goes to be 3 or it
goes to be three i keep right rook g to
look is 707 maybe i should do this
actually intending rook d3 and still
nothing going on ready no I just give
away a six know yeah this is how you can
lose it of course if you just blunder
way upon was for nothing ah great yeah
the compass basically just shuffling
around with no no plan or whatever and
the only way to lose it is blunder born
in one which I managed to do great
really great
I still still slight chances to draw
maybe at least no reason to to resign
yeah check here and take and it will
take you to have no choice other things
are definitely lost okay so um there is
this check i taked here I'll take them
actually I know it's probably lost
anyway still lost our work g6 ester is
the key point and yeah okay
yeah unfortunately there's the check iam
so King on the third is not leading to
anything we are very very idiotic am it
was like nothing and I play King c7
which is of course really a yeah totally
useless ok let's see huh u6 I always
like it when the computer place the
Kings Indian to be honest the scandal
structured really cannot play so let's
try for something simple here Dutch kind
of position Queen the screen check is
retaining I really don't want to give
our porn for our fishy compensation like
c4 Queen B form so let's just play it
very very simple preparing me for I am
ok I can actually play your form I am ok
interesting if i take here should be to
my it's not really that great computer
can play rupee ahead and pin me on my
bishop huh crazy and if i go g5 it will
go to reform that's not really great hmm
ok
we should be five yeah Bishop b5 Bishop
d7 looks yeah maybe still just just take
it and play for for Bishop four nights
against bishop wow wow yeah i was
thinking that this could be a good idea
but still I thought that the computer
would not play it before before there's
a 50 k 9 p-3 this Bishop a for I am
great I don't know probably takes tech
c-5m not much to do him ok so I'm going
to take I put put this thing on deform
night is coming to the three
there's rooks III as long
can I do know a force thanks B form
yeah I'm not really sure how to continue
to play him can I if I cannot enter you
with the King a bit get out 22 or
something maybe a jiff I should cover f4
like here but this night see one as well
here King the two words not really
leading to too much King d two rooks it
oozes on no King the two blunders f2
though ok so that is not an idea at all
in general I don't really know how to
play him it's very eerie really limited
in a way here with my ideas this rook on
c3 and stuff this this is very very very
annoying I have a hard time to move my
move my pieces really poor if I play
yeah justjust back or something I really
don't have a plan here yeah there is
there is no plan f ok ok there's this I
have not seen it all what is the point
of it might be three probably
might be 3m yeah the computer controls
the only opened higher yeah that's the
problem and very weird stuff from the
opening yeah I know this Bishop is
coming to e4 which is devastating Wow
and on all the time this bloody tactics
of oxy one Bishop d3 yeah I cannot allow
the bishop to e4 yeah if this is
happening I might as well resign I mean
so I'll take it it's probably probably
lost anyway because I mean night is
coming to d3 and stuff I don't even I
don't think there is this in any way
defendable he's just in the two details
just invading yeah I rook c2 and and so
on amazing how quickly this this went
downhill from a pretty much weird
opening but yeah it's really no defense
IAM
what is the big idea here is f3 that
devastating double check f3 Wow f3 this
is this is a nice loss allow that I'm
toasting anyway so I allow that f3 this
is very cute night you want double check
Kingair for work every maid I have seen
this but it's just too nice to not allow
you know that that's nice okay I'm going
to play one final game yeah the position
right of the opening was really bad this
cam sometimes sometimes sometimes
difficult really to to play it looks
very weird like set up as d 5 f-5 was
very strong I really it gets the night
to reform what can you do it is it is
just a good position all of a sudden
okay so can I kick it kick it first snow
a complete development yeah this is the
kind of move that really lets you then
we'll hit it it's just like I mean
putting it out there losing a tempo for
nothing but it's still not leading to
something great from like the kind of
move no human would ever play but it's
not they're not losing or so super
terrible okay um can probably pawn takes
um yeah maybe Knight to Knight to f4 joe
night c4 might come to d6 if I just
jumped night on d6
okay i don't really have great squares
for former hook
hmm
f6 is very ugly yeah it's also Bishop c4
yeah that's a really idiotic idea okay
um what about Bishop f6 just trying to
trade stuff yeah I don't know I already
don't like my position back to it I
really don't know okay well that's not
really really dangerous i guess if I
know just go back here
not a very human if they are putting the
rook on this kind of insecure square
which only protects by the night and be
fibers in the in there but I mean II
five is attacked just just as simple as
that so hmm yeah where do I go maybe he
edged simply go maybe I can really play
f6 Bishop e-cigs rook da to this kind of
thing wow that's really ugly okay come
on and be sure we say I know g7 hangs
there in age six hangs King g7 or blah
maybe age 5 35 not not nice the biggest
problem is that i cannot really compete
for 48 yeah with rook the aid the shop
here 96's rudy some maybe rook e77
attacking a seven yeah whatever okay at
least this is some trades i'm pretty
glad that I could actually trade some
things um night 85 is still still
possible if I just take take here 1c for
ugly very ugly stuff night a five rupee
am this is still somewhat summer holes
and them in a way maybe I can
no I wanted to say I'm 3g 64 my night
okay what is it at the end of it I
should probably just walk over with a
king right Knight a5 I have rugby aid
night will probably come to the six but
shouldn't be that terrible ok will be
eight now ok I know come on yeah really
this kind of stuff is working Bishop c8
or what
okay where's the night going d3 to see
five years so I'm going to try to where
are you going to see form see form okay
g-form not really g'nite to d8 is he
actually then forced to no one even then
it's not force night where d7d 7b six
maybe nah f5 I get step 5
they are that that is why playing
against computer is no fun yeah they've
played this inhuman stuff like Bishop a6
yeah and I mean and then just stay there
like this is the normal the normal thing
to do there should be seven nine am-2
awesome David would be 798 okay maybe
one more to make it one hour oh man
dad's always frustrating against the
machine especially I mean again I mean I
was basically out of it just Bishop a6
was coming I mean I really had a bad
position at first but i don't think the
computer played it particularly well and
then be sure a six was coming ook yeah
modern benoni that's not a great opening
against the comp it will probably miss
player totally but it is always so murky
and you'd ever get a closed position
ready and I'm modern benoni now it
starts with I mean the night is simply
wrong 1c7 but not sure how I poured it
will be at the end
okay really age five so should I just
put it on g5 going for tween f4 stuff
one okay just that freeing age one
okay so i can actually trade the dark
squared bishop now that's in fact a
debatable thing that because the
computer has night f for coming in very
short order when Queen g5 stuff like
that hmm night be 595 is normally good
because yeah a seven hangs the night
Hanks but maybe computer can really just
take and play night f form King edge 125
up to one that looks cool it looks fishy
somehow right age three at the end
that's a great great move if I play
Knight g4 here what is the computers
reply actually it cannot really take i
think i was thinking that taking and
getting to be fire should be good but
maybe not tough okay well i can also
take with the bishop which yeah why not
actually there should be a really weak
ponen on the d farm okay um I have to go
back on course and now we're to c 6 mmm
yeah I guess
okay so this is an active night and it
has tonight e 2 coming still still I
should probably try to take this pawn
king everyone and then it is really
hanging ok takes now ok then but I have
rookie 3m setting up the pin on that
yeah okay so let's let's grab and here
now the pin is an effect rook e1 yeah
that's not as great as I thought but ok
why why why am i sorry sorry I can do
that of course you cannot play EP 8 or a
silly idea this kind of thing is really
saving mmm that would be really on ham
if i take it you should take skin d1 we
should move okay so let's not it's not
that great really it's this fair I don't
think it is okay
okay okie seven some are trying to
invade but I don't see how I really
don't see how to attack him yeah rookie
7 is not really leading to much if I
give the check here maybe just a check
actually that's a good and simple
solution rookie 7s very active so
probably this is at least no it's not
wrong so yeah so it wants to invade but
I can also attack here okay
now black can enter but okay well anyway
I need to play that I mean so no use in
spending time here so rook takes here
and then what Bishop everyone on what
kind of thing I guess no one is just
protected aw c'mon editor's too late him
10 okay I'm okay okay okay this was too
late too long I'm sorry that this was
like two totally bad okay yeah but then
I was already thinking I can take the
porn then Bishop f1 and so on is is is
going to be going to be a problem yeah
it was weird really I mean you can
really play all this crap and still it
okay with black you want it it really
seems like this ideas like rookie f7
some will save the day or maybe this is
through this is just wrong yeah I should
really win a porn yeah so I have to
start with this probably this wins the
porn right with Luke a one and take on
your form
yeah maybe because this wins the pawn
that that's possible I'm not totally
positive but but maybe maybe yeah it is
always tough against the machine um I
still hope you enjoyed it though I got a
proper beating and wasn't really in good
shape it's not that great trollee to
start matches like that at 1am but ok I
just wanted to try ok i hope you liked
it anyway thanks for watching